cuando yo era niño
había una pregunta que constantemente
venía a mi cabeza y una pregunta que no
necesariamente me hacía porque era yo
muy inteligente sino porque simplemente
soy un ser humano y la pregunta era por
qué por qué pasan las cosas mamá porque
hay que ir a la escuela porque tengo que
estudiar esta materia
porque ocurren las cosas que ocurren y
así un día cuando estaba ya un poco más
grande como a los 7 años estábamos
poniendo el árbol de navidad en casa y
pregunté
porque estamos poniendo el árbol de
navidad y mi mamá contesto muy
claramente pues porque es navidad pedro
no pero porque mamá porque es tradición
tal vez yo no era un niño más
inteligente que los otros pero creo que
mis padres fueron inteligentes al jamás
detener las preguntas
jamás de ellos recibí un cállate lo
hacemos porque lo digo yo o tienes que
hacerlo porque soy tu padre simplemente
me permitían seguir preguntando por qué
por qué por qué y esa pregunta me
persiguió durante mucho tiempo
la vida me ha enseñado que esa pregunta
es fundamental no hacer las cosas porque
tienes que hacerlas sino porque tú
entiendes para qué sirven esas cosas
y el estar buscando la respuesta a esta
pregunta es lo que ha hecho que el ser
humano construya cultura es decir la
cultura es la respuesta a la pregunta
por qué por qué estamos aquí
hace algunos años ya cuando estaba más
adulto en mi primer trabajo tuve la
oportunidad de decidir qué hacer con mi
sueldo afortunadamente los gastos de
casa los cubría papá y mamá y tenía la
oportunidad de decidir qué hacer con ese
dinero así que tomé la decisión de
ahorrar ahorrar y ahorrar tenía un
sueldo de becario así que no era mucho y
ahorre durante un año un año y medio
hasta que pude comprar un boleto para
viajar a europa era un sueño que tenía
en particular y quería viajar a europa
porque quería entender mejor el mundo
quería que no me contaran las cosas sino
ir a verlas yo personalmente así es que
compré un viaje méxico parís sólo en
alcanzó para eso estando en parís por
supuesto había que ir a ver las cosas
que me habían dicho que eran importantes
de parís y una de esas cosas era el
museo de luz si han estado en el museo
luz es enorme cientos de obras de arte
muchas galerías pero sobre todo mucha
gente
cientos de personas en una galería yendo
de un lugar a otro y había una pieza en
particular que quería conocer y esa era
la monalisa porque porque me habían
dicho que había que conocerla
así es que recorrió el museo me cansé de
un lugar a otro y finalmente llegó el
momento de ir a conocer esta pieza
quienes han estado ahí a la mejor podrán
recordar que esa gran galería tiene un
muro gigantesco y al dar la vuelta el
corazón empieza a latir fuertemente y te
topas con un cristal y una gran valla y
cientos de personas cientos de personas
haciendo lo que les dijeron que hicieran
no tomen fotografías y las toman
y lo vi y mi corazón se deshizo porque
el muro es gigante y el cuadro es muy
pequeño
y entonces me di cuenta que lo que había
pasado es que yo ha generado una enorme
expectativa sobre algo que me habían
dicho que era importante me sentía en
una esquina de la me senté en una
pequeña esquina de la galería y lo que
hice fue más bien observar el fenómeno
humano de la gente viendo esa pieza
y me di cuenta que la mayor parte de la
gente que estaba ahí estaba porque le
habían dicho que había que ir pero pocos
estaban entendiendo lo que veían
así es que posaban se tomaban
fotografías y hacían comentarios y se
reían pero prácticamente nadie estaba
entendiendo porque eso era una obra de
arte importante
y entonces la monalisa me abrió los ojos
y me hizo entender que yo no quería ser
un ser humano que iba por la vida
haciendo lo que le decían sino
comprendiendo lo que pasaba en el mundo
y que aquellas cosas que no me parecían
buenas era posible cambiarlas porque
todo lo que creemos en el mundo no es
una realidad es una invención creada a
partir de la cultura que entendemos
cuando era niño también tuve oportunidad
de viajar y mi punto de referencia en
eeuu era un niño de siete años que fue a
eeuu y cuando regresó regresaba siempre
enfadado porque decía mamá porque el
aeropuerto de méxico no es tan bonito
porque los prados no son verdes porque
las rosas no se dan en los jardines
porque la gente tira al abuso en la
calle como le contestas a un niño de 7
años que eso pasa porque no vive en el
primer mundo es un poco decepcionante y
con el tiempo y la vida me fui dando
cuenta que nosotros los otros países no
eran mejores o peores simplemente eran
diferentes y me hizo preguntarme qué
hace a un país poderoso que hace que una
nación sea más poderosa que otra llegué
a la conclusión que no eran las armas y
no era la economía era la capacidad que
tienen los países poderosos de influir
en otros a partir de su cultura o los
pueblos de américa latina' hablamos
español porque la cultura que conquistó
este territorio al español pero también
en el español hay palabras de origen
árabe
que son el origen de otro pueblo que
conquistó a ese otro territorio y así
hoy comprendemos el mundo a través del
cine norteamericano porque es la
potencia que rige la cultura del mundo y
entendemos las familias la sociedad el
trabajo y las estructuras sociales a
partir lo que su cine nos dice y ahí
está el poder de la cultura entonces nos
damos cuenta que por encima de las armas
y la economía lo que rige al mundo es la
cultura lo que creemos en que creemos
para dónde vamos el territorio qué
entendemos cómo en méxico fue
conquistado no por las armas sino por la
cultura
los conquistadores pidieron a españa que
mandarán más padres y menos soldados
porque con un padre era posible
controlar una población de 500 indios y
si traían armas tenían que tener a 500
soldados para 500 indios no era
escalable
esta investigación y este proceso de
entender me ha llevado más a fondo
y particularmente ver esta pieza me hace
pensar en el ser humano hace 30 mil años
que nos quiso decir el hombre al plasmar
esto
y nos quiso decir algo muy cercano a lo
que entendemos nos quiso decir aquí
estuve yo el ser humano tiene la
capacidad de comprender que va a morir
y lo comprendemos desde que somos
pequeños y el hecho de saber con
anticipación que vamos a morir provoca
en nosotros una enorme necesidad de
trascender de sentir que pasó algo con
nosotros entonces repente basa en la
calle y si te encuentras un poco de
cemento fresco y pones tu pie y un metro
que dice aquí estuvo pedro bueno es un
poco lo mismo que esto no muy civilizado
y no se enfada pero es la condición
humana queremos decirle al mundo que
pasamos por ahí algunos lo hacen en el
baño otros lo hacen pintando arte
esta pieza que está de las manos
colocadas está profundamente conectada
con van gogh o está conectada con frida
kahlo o está conectado con diego rivera
o con siqueiros porque todos quisieron
decir lo mismo aquí estuve yo esto
pensaba esto era yo y esta necesidad
profunda en ser humano de construir
trascendencia genera cultura
lo que provoca que el ser humano genera
cultura en realidad son dos cosas que
ninguna otra especie puede hacer una
somos un animal chismoso nos encanta
chismosear que hacemos los seres humanos
cuando terminamos de comer
si es mi amor no y empezamos a hablar de
la vida de las cosas que pasan
criticamos al de enfrente y chief games
y abusa chisme amos con quien ni
siquiera conocemos puesto en el
aeropuerto y encuentro alguien cerca de
mí y ocurre algo y chisme amos fíjate
que no estoy de acuerdo con esto y
empezamos a hablar de cosas y el chisme
nos lleva a otra cosa magnífica que es
la ficción es decir empezamos a inventar
cosas a partir de lo que creemos que son
porque empezamos a darle significado a
las cosas que no comprendemos hay una
película que cuando yo era niño de me
hizo referencia a esto justamente no
recibieron ustedes el rey león'
pero hay una escena en el rey león donde
hay tres personajes timón y pumba y
simba que están en el pasto viendo al
cielo y después de haber comido insectos
y de haberse cansado y haber cantado y
haber hecho todo lo que tenían que hacer
ya no tenía nada más que hacer así es
que tenían que holgazanear y chismear y
mientras veían el cielo se preguntaban
qué serán esas cosas que brillan allá
arriba uno de ellos dice son unas bolas
de fuego que se queman a kilómetros
y aquí hay otro que dice para mí son
luciérnagas que se quedaron pegadas en
esa cosa azul que está ahí arriba
y sin ver les dice para mí son los reyes
del pasado que nos observan y nos cuidan
lo que hicieron fue tratar de dar
significado al mundo a partir del chisme
y crear una ficción lo que hoy
entendemos por dios o por gobierno o por
familia en realidad es una ficción que
hemos construido la ficción es la
capacidad que tenemos los seres humanos
de creer en algo porque nos convencieron
que eso es así y en ese sentido
el ser humano construye mitos alrededor
de esas ficciones y esa y esos chismes
que contamos los mitos nos dan orden nos
dan estructura
y los mitos nos permiten generar algo
que para no ser humano es mágico
es un acto de abracadabra
de pronto yo tengo aquí a una persona
con una toga y un birrete y de este lado
tengo una persona que tiene una
investidura y en el centro entre usted
entre él y yo hay un documento y le
pusimos diploma y si ustedes creen que
esta persona es un alumno y que yo soy
el rector y que este diploma es válido
en automático esta persona se convierte
licenciado pero tiene que creer ustedes
si ustedes no lo creen eso no pasa si
este papel es tan poderoso para que
ustedes lo crean porque los
convencimientos les pasará el ser humano
hace todo a partir de la magia de que
convenzamos a los demás de que así es
así funciona entonces el matrimonio pero
también el noviazgo y si me dicen que me
aman
entonces me amarán y me sentiré contento
y si me dicen que me odian me sentiría
triste pero es un acto de de hacer que
las palabras
cobren vida y eso señores es la cultura
es la capacidad que tiene el ser humano
de transformar las cosas que cree en
realidades
saludo a mi infancia porque de ella
vienen muchas de mis referencias que
después me construyeron como adulto y
una película que también me hizo pensar
muchas cosas se llamaba el mago de öz
hay una escena al final del mago de öz
en la que el espantapájaros el hombre de
hojalata y él y él y el león
descubren que el mago de öz no es más
que un charlatán sin embargo él saca un
costal y a cada uno de ellos les entrega
algo al espantapájaros les da un diploma
al león le entrega una medalla de valor
y al hombre de hojalata el entregado un
reloj en forma de corazón y en
automático los personajes empiezan a
reaccionar de una manera diferente el
espantapájaros siente que es inteligente
el el león empieza a sentirse valiente y
de pronto el hombre de hojalata escucha
que late el corazón porque el reloj hace
tic tac
y ese se abra a cada hora del que les
hablo a veces basta que alguien nos diga
que somos para que lo seamos y basta que
la cultura nos diga quiénes somos para
que creamos que somos eso somos el país
que queremos creer que somos pero
también podríamos ser el país que
nosotros decidamos que queramos ser a
partir de construir la cultura que
construyamos
cultura entonces es crear significados
y lo que les diría es que el gran poder
que debe tener un líder es la capacidad
que tenga no de ser una víctima de la
cultura en la que vive si una capacidad
que tenga de construir la cultura en la
que quiere vivir y si hay un significado
en el que no cree tiene que cambiarlo y
tiene que tener poder de convencer a los
otros para que ese significado sea
valioso y poderoso y lo sigan la cultura
señores es construir un significado y
hoy somos la consecuencia de la cultura
que hemos querido comprar cómo le
explicas a un niño que su país no gana
ninguna medalla en los juegos olímpicos
cómo le haces creer a un niño que en
este país tal vez no se puede ser el
mejor bailarín del mundo porque no
tenemos una cultura de la danza clásica
por ejemplo y sin embargo ha habido sin
embargo han habido medallistas y han
habido grandes bailarines en este país
porque han roto la cultura que se les
había impuesto y han construido una
propia
cultura es lo más poderoso que puede
crear un ser humano
en la ficción que nos hace creer cosas y
transformar el mundo a nuestro gusto y
entonces lo que les diría yo es no seas
una víctima de la cultura que está
alrededor construye la propia forma la
diseña la y entonces ve al mundo a
tratar de transformarlo no simplemente
vivamos con lo que nos dijeron que tenía
que pasar la pregunta importante aquí es
tú qué significado estás construyendo
si simplemente vas por la vida
escuchando lo que pasa o creas un
significado diferente hay instituciones
que a lo largo de nuestra vida van
construyendo ese significado el primero
es la familia
después entran las escuelas
después entran las empresas o las
instituciones productivas y también ahí
está el gobierno y estas cuatro
instituciones tendrían que invertir
tiempo y recursos en construir cultura
en dar un bagaje de opciones de
conocimiento y entendimiento humano que
le permitan a la persona no solamente
recibir lo que queremos que hagan sino
cuestionar una sociedad que no cuestiona
nada una sociedad que simplemente va por
la línea que le dijeron que era lo que
tenía que hacer es una sociedad quien no
construye cultura y una sociedad que no
construye cultura es una sociedad
determinada a fracasar o siempre está en
un segundo término si queremos que
nuestro país sea un país poderoso
tendríamos que invertir más en cultura y
no se refiere nada más a generar arte se
refiere a generar conocimiento
entendimiento ciencia sociabilidad
comunicación y humanismo
finalmente
todo lo que les he dicho hasta ahora es
una ficción
sin embargo si he podido ser un poquito
convincente con ustedes entonces empecé
a construir un poquito de cultura aquí
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]